[Música]
há dois mil anos atrás conseguiu acionar
cícero escrever um tratado é retórica é
chamado de oratória e disse que a
história era magistrado deve ter
ou seja é mestra da vida porque na
verdade através das eleições que a
história nos dá nós podemos construir
uma série de serviços que vão ajudar a
lidar melhor com o cruzeiro e até com um
estudo preparado no futuro mas antes
isso muito rapidamente
alguns aspectos básicos é todos os lados
humanos consideraram constroem idéias
comportamentos momento 77 são
genericamente designado cultura o
património cultural pode ser o material
pkk segmento ante fatia ou imaterial
casas idéias comportamentos rr certa
forma primeira vez que nós temos trás e
precisamos acho que gerações vindouras
enquanto consocial é memória é certa
forma cria um espírito de união entre o
grupo através da pressão que não tem das
semelhanças e diferenças entre nós e os
outros e é essa nobre que o componente
fundamental para a criação da identidade
que é construir e agrada também ao longo
do tempo mas que ouvir muito bom ter uma
história não no modelo vão passar pela
história mas também passar muito longe
cué e passar simbólico que tem uma cara
é muito importante o movimento que em
momentos de crise a manutenção de guerra
as transmissões com que toda essa
pergunta questionando de certa forma a
sociedade perde a fé na sua capacidade
para ultrapassar os obstáculos que se
nos deparam se com seu portugal começava
em 2010 portugal viu-se mergulhado em
uma crise financeira profunda é
conseqüência em certa medida uma crise
internacional que afetou muitos países
do sul da europa ea irlanda e em 2011 o
governo português sobre um empréstimo de
78 mil milhões de euros para evitar a
bancarrota
tem que fazer um plano de ajustamento
permanentemente monitorizado pelas
instituições que os tinham conseguido o
empréstimo
os empréstimos foram cumprir porque o
edifício com todos estarão lembrados o
período em que aumentava os impostos um
período em que reduzirão salários um
período em que aumentou o desemprego em
que foram escutados serviço público 60
que a crise foi é esse período de
dúvidas e incertezas foi praticamente
notado no norte de portugal e no porto
foi aí que muitas pessoas ficam com
muito serviço foram 1º fórum subitamente
sem fradinhos descentralizados em lisboa
quer privados que quer público é é
aquele que foi usado como justificação
para uma maior centralização e isso teve
um impacto muito negativo em x contratos
de locações forçados não atende para
lisboa o porto que sempre seguiu
preterido em formar uma boa foi em
demais durante este período de crise
então vamos nós neste trio nesta época
quando eu achei que ia tentar fazer
alguma coisa para inverter a situação
obviamente que não tinha 78 milhões de
filiados podem pintar no clube português
mas fazer qualquer coisa que se ouve
criar uma máquina do tempo não é
exatamente uma máquina do tempo como
aquelas leite o alvo é é um aparelho que
conseguiu transportar as pessoas não
tenham a mesma coisa mais simples bem a
minha escala que era uma página no
facebook para chamadas novas chamas por
desaparecido e era uma página com o
objectivo de partilhar histórias do
porto para que as fotografias do porto e
fazer com que as pessoas vissem a
custódia como uma fonte de motivação
para vencer os desafios que tem pela
frente e ver como não me deixe por
desaparecido tem acima do objetivo de
mostrar aquilo que se perdeu na frágil
do tempo em que muitas vezes surpreende
o porto vença é atual e por isso
confiamos também as pessoas participaram
nessa discussão a partilharem também
suas memórias em particular em também as
suas ideias que connosco
assim a casa tentava tratava de ver o
futebol português o que é isso evita por
doença
há uma série de dimensões que de certa
forma constitui em argamassa nessa idade
e dessa evitar doença em 2012 vivências
da população que são mais elementar
algumas das quatro programas
considerados mais importantes uma delas
é o primado um sempre mal do porto no
contexto da portugalidade através da
própria conceção do nome portugal é
portugal
aquela cidade é aquele local onde houve
nome portugal como cantava o caminho com
respeito o fato de um por ser a cidade
natal da banda nasceu o infante dom
henrique
grande personagem chapa descobrimentos
portugueses a dispensar muitos respeito
à participação da população não só na
questão da armada que foi conquistar seu
tamanho 415 mas principalmente ao lutar
com os navios com carnes área seja
portugueses deram na chuva e descargas e
ficaram com as vistas e daí esse epíteto
tripeiro que ainda hoje os portugueses
sustenta
depois um pouco mais o ambiente no
século 18 o senhor direcionado junto ao
mar e mel com seu filho foram
responsáveis pelo não tem revolução
urbana na cidade do porto é conseguir o
que importa de emergências as muralhas
frangas ultrapassar essas moradias foram
vendidas morais do dia faz 61 autos
muito estreito e comprido tenham
simplesmente 50 m de largura e podiam
ter comprimento que ia até 50c médio que
acontece e sempre um impacto muito
grande não só na organização do cigarro
como também nas identidades é do porto é
trás dessas à frente de casas vias
estreitas e traz esse comboio nas casas
as ilhas onde se foram os que esperam
onde foram colhidas e ávine as pessoas
podiam do campo para a cidade
nessa exposição do porto do século 19
num inquérito feito em 1899 apurou se
que um terço da população do porto
exigia facto é
estas que não é só vivemos nesse aspecto
há muitos outros aspectos também
episódio histórico de certa forma foram
identificados e também constituem essa
área massa de inventar por doença
desde logo é a forma como por se bateu
pela primeira vez pela não permanência
de final tinha assinado o prestígio
internacional do vinho do porto
o papel da comunidade britânica na
cidade há três anos aponta as marcas ea
ocupação francesa o cerco do porto numa
altura em que tem um porto contra todos
e um porteiro do lado certo e quero ser
vencedor da história recebeu como
recompensa o coração joão pedro eo tempo
de infectar os que estão na cidade
almeida garrett que meu castelo branco
eugénio de andrade final bryan na china
o porto é uma cidade literária dos
cursos que todos têm uma importância
muito grande também na profissão devem
tirado em português
esqueça o twitter eixos pressionar né na
carta enviada esta usar por bispo do
porto antónio ferreira gomes que falou e
se ele ou o poeta da cidade opõem
incondicional da cidade ao joão humberto
delgado em 1958 na cidade o trabalho
capital do trabalho
não raro é palavra dada a subir a pulso
ter o nome na praça das contas à moda do
porto rio douro o timbre para decente
como cantava reforço do clube para a
cidade do porto
souto moura e siza vieira e
generalizadas causa de captura do porto
os marciais o comércio tradicional
o fármaco por doenças ou forma que
encontrei e fotografia representar o
jornal português
agora já tivemos aquela cara de espanto
e arquitetos que estão na aprovação de
empreendimentos conformar com o
português
alguém espontaneidade a festa popular
que o são joão com por ser o centro do
porto sem história e do património da
humanidade
obviamente não temos que ser perfeitos
nacionais e internacionais do principal
clube de futebol pois tudo isso
constitui é evitar que se tudo isso se
procurava tratar na página pode ser
possível
tanto não se procura não se cria e
tentava se que a página não fosse uma
faixa saudosista mas foi assim mattoso
como jafri uma página que as pessoas
preferem ir atrás e gastar eu acho que
aí se conseguir ganhar força esperando
para continuarem em frente é preciso ter
um processo muito rápido
o fim do ano já tinha cerca de 20 mil é
seguir nossa página a opção isso porto
gaia e matosinhos trabalha mas também de
lisboa londres e do rio de janeiro não
vai dar porque não só a brincar vamos às
pessoas que viviam aqui nessa região do
porto mas também todos os portugueses
que estavam em certa forma espalhados
pelo mundo
a câmara do porto tomou pressão dessa
dessa importância na valorização do
património e da história e em abril de
considero me uma medalha municipal de
mérito que me deixou satisfeito que eu
saiba foi a única vez
a primeira única em que a câmara do
porto por miguel alguém por ter criado
uma página no facebook
se eu tivesse só que foi um pouco esse
sms impacto positivo e isso nossas
sugestões também que eu fui percebendo
que não vai dar um passo mais além de um
pouco é mais uma vez que na verdade uma
página permite um contacto é algo
superficial mais precisa possível
dimensionar e procurava um pouco mais
além e criar algo mais envolvente e
traseiros pessoas arrancaram os shows de
casa e traziam espera o castigado que
nos locais visitados onde passaram facto
os acontecimentos históricos em obsessão
com uma empresa de animação turística
organizamos um primeiro percurso em
janeiro de 2003 chamada antigos
hospitais do porto em que visitarmos não
só os túneis do hospital santo antônio
como tanques de antigas instalações do
hospital antigo hospital dom pedro
almeida que durante séculos foi maior
hospital do porto e que hoje é quase
desconhecido sucesso vamos fazer muitas
outras fontes o percurso temos mais de
30 percurso diferente em que os temas
são os mais variados aqui por exemplo
fizemos recentemente nicolau nasoni
somadas os ingleses brasileiros
torrenciais
que deus engenharias ctg fesa teatro
remail tudo isso são elementos que nos
servem de motivação de criação para onde
estamos para o curso o curso de maior
sucesso que temos é um chama pelos
técnicos do porto onde vamos
há vários táticos casas pastoral dos
tradicionais com menos - e falamos sobre
histórias do porto em portugal estamos
pensando ainda no passado sábado
lançamos um novo percurso senado
composto do contra porque na verdade a
personalidade do porto parece muito
marcado para 17 pedro bial espera de um
certo espírito protesto e por isso
contavam no segundo tempo começaram por
teste sobre essas conspirações mutange e
revoluções e fomos nessa viagem no tempo
indo aos locais onde se passaram série
de emoções emitentes interessantes e
curiosas por exemplo a fifa se viu no
fundo esta imagem estão ver foi criado
em fevereiro de 1927 quando portugal em
armas contra a ditadura e durante uma
semana existiu é as forças
governamentais mais mil pessoas ficaram
feridas mais de 200 pessoas no porto
morreram 36 mesmo mas ao menos cem anos
de história é essa está bem com as
conhecidas da maioria dos portugueses
nós essa foi minha história mas com
tanques na semana passada
temos recursos em português a pensar num
público local
é contando histórias mostradas imagens
mapas fotografias lembra que muitos na
época para que as pessoas possam mais
facilmente mg surgisse cara e nessas
nessa nesse ambiente que nós pretendemos
no tema que podemos tratar e deve usar
seis anos de mostrar um portal portuense
uma vez mais dele que importa e
portuenses sentido de que o vila nova de
gaia inclui estamos falando do grande
porto nem sempre bem como vemos as vezes
de bicicleta também do metro de marco
legal tocar isso no início era é era
muito com a crise teve a chance até nós
pois é muito mais a massificação do
turismo que atrai as pessoas que esperam
por doença na cidade de cruzeiro mais a
sua história ea sociedade conhecer o
património que ainda temos entre nós
a chave o turismo trouxe traz uma série
de vantagens uma grande vantagem para
ocupar a região norte perdendo para o
porto é nomeadamente na criação de
emprego nomeadamente até do próprio
reconversão verificava baixa de seu
histórico de gaia e do porto no entanto
coloca também desafios da preservação do
do patrimônio principalmente material
também na preservação da identidade
também não precisa de memória é
reconhecer que as pessoas nesta altura
em que tem mais três de altura que
também tem mais interessa em conhecer a
autenticidade isto avançou na cidade é
de facto estes autores da globalização
que não podemos mais nossas raízes que
não podemos mais apostou em nós
diferente dos outros o movimento que é o
passava o que é algo que nossa fé é algo
que não se pode alterar essa é uma linha
contínua é no entanto é a uma série de
lições podemos tirar do passado que não
são úteis espera para o futuro é o tema
2009 o tempo de mudar esse tempo também
de equilíbrio
o certo é que nos convida certa forma é
apressaram se a mudança nas suas
diversas dimensões mas também por outro
lado a preservar é isso
o astro histórico que nos dá com
equilíbrio
acho que por ser parecido já conta hoje
em dia com mais cem mil seguida hoje que
tem que é uma equipa com o seu sonho é
uma equipe que trata dessa página e
também da equipa que está por trás dos
percursos que temos vindo a fazer nos
últimos seis anos requisitaram que a
nossa escala temos contribuído para uma
nova recessão
é da história local como a conseqüente
melhoria da autoestima de pops
portuenses e que estamos reconstruir
também apresentaram ensinar e que estão
os alicerces importantes para a
construção de um futuro brilhante
[Aplausos]
[Música]